this past weekend you know it huh what
is that
boy that's a Turk
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate misery
[Music]
so
gonna die
[Music]
welcome Happy Thanksgiving
that's what it is you know that it is
Thanksgiving it is November 23rd you
know it's that pilgrim partay you know
this that time when if you know if you
got a Native American friend you you
tell them to step aside because you got
to eat this Thanksgiving time and this
is a beautiful time of year and this is
a Thanksgiving episode of this past
weekend November 23rd in 2017 planet
Earth galaxy alpha one I think we're an
alpha one I still need to look that up I
need to do a little bit of galaxy
research you know and I will do that as
soon as I get around to it I've still
got other stuff to Google and I'm trying
to unsubscribe from a lot of emails from
different banking establishments but
thank you guys for being here happy
happy Thanksgiving to you to your
families to your loved ones and to the
people you hate and that's something I'm
trying to do right now my life is prop
up these people that I hate man I'll be
hating dude dude if you tapped uh if you
tape you put a spigot in the side of me
and you spilled something out into a cup
and you taste it I bet that would be
just a dang probably at least a half
pint of hater sauce because it's easy
for me to hate man but today I'm
thinking about gratitude I'm thinking
about being thankful and I just want to
say that I'm thankful for you guys
thankful for the support that song was
by Spencer Jacob growl Spencer Jacob
growl and as I look right now
into my emails and I see Spencer Jacob
growl about nine months ago I get an
email from this beautiful man here's the
intro music and he says music for you to
use that's what he said
music for you to use it's we we call
celebrate and that's a song that he sent
in and uh and I'm thankful to him so I'm
thankful for that
I'm thankful I got a producer helping me
out today a gentleman by the name of
Budd Galloway and he's a young man
pretty symmetrical looking fella looks
like he could be maybe be a mountain
climber or something who knows but Budd
Galloway at Lisa coming in today young
Budd Galloway and I'm thankful for that
fella hit me up off the internet and
what are you thankful for today you
thinking about it are you thinking about
it cuz I'll list some things off I will
list some things off that I'm thankful
for if you can't think of if you can't
think of something you're thankful for
that's on you pat pat okay even a senior
citizen can think of something that they
are thankful for go wake up a senior
citizen I dare you - how dare you - and
after they get past the fear of
realizing they're still alive ask them
something they're thankful for and they
will know some things because a senior
citizen usually full of gratitude unless
they have gone past that latitude of
gratitude and gone out and just into the
depths you know and let's say out into
the depths where all they can do is just
you know beg you to kill him on the side
of the dinner table you know we just
have a great great something I don't
even know who he was I don't even think
it was related to us I think he was just
so old that um he started coming around
and I think he might have tricked my dad
and him you know or or somebody in our
family and I realized he was related to
us you know coz what my dad being so old
when I was growing up you know you'd
have men that was you know if a 90 year
old stop by you know you just assume
that dad knew him you know but this old
man kind of tricked us into thinking we
was related to him he'd come by for the
holidays and he was probably he could
have been anywhere from 90 to maybe a
hundred and thirty and he used to beg us
to end his misery after dinner and that
always kind of shook me a little bit and
we here's what made me think there was
like yeah oh you eatin first but then
you trying to get you know get one of
the local children and you know knock
you off you know it always was a little
bit ironic to me that the man
to imbibe in dinner first before we
started looking for death so I don't
know if he really wanted to die if he
just didn't like digestion you know
maybe at that age he didn't like you
know having to go to the bathroom by
himself or something I don't know
it's a while but I know that that man
was so old we just believed he was
related to us and he would come around
and eat you know sergeant what was Henry
I think it was named sergeant Henry
that's what that's what everybody called
him sergeant and he would come and eat
with us and uh and then on the side of
the dinner table he would beg us to
knock him off ER you know put a pillow
over him or something but anyhow Happy
Thanksgiving you know and that's
Thanksgiving it's not always just prim
and proper and everything you know and
if you don't have any turkey this time
of year I'll tell you what you can eat
you can catch a head of that gray block
pizza you know one of our sponsors happy
to have them always happy to have gray
block you know if you're in Los Angeles
and your stomachs empty change it up
treat your stomach to something fancy
something good something filling hit
that gray block Pizza on Pico Boulevard
on the way to the beach catch that hit
up I'm thankful to them for coming on
this year I'm thankful all the patreon
errs let's be patreon astana you guys
want to do that but if you can't think
of some things for Thanksgiving man I uh
I'm a label some things for you
okay I'm gonna label some things for you
right out of the friggin Gizzi here's
something hair
do you have hair well are you grateful
for it are you just running around
thinking you have hair forever because
I'll tell you this if you's a young buck
and you got a lot of hair on your head
if you up their cockadoodle in' you know
in peacocking and showing strands whoo
you better enjoy that time find you a
woman now because once that hair starts
uh you know leaving anything can happen
once that hair starts leaving anything
can happen you might end up
you know having to work at a circus you
might end up you know having to change
the style of women that you like datin
real real short short short women
because sometime they'll go for the you
know men that are missing hair so if you
got that hair get you something now my
mother used to date this man um Charlie
mr. Charlie and he was in some of the
wars and he started losing hair but he
grew his eyebrows out the man had
eyebrows like a dam he had eyebrows like
a you know like a like an Italian you
know it's like an Italian carpet
salesman dude had huge eye brows I mean
I bet if you'd have cut the hair off of
each brow probably weighed about a
thirtieth of a pound and he had huge
eyebrows and that man started combing
his eyebrows back into his hair because
that's how much a man must have hair so
if you have a hair on your head that's
something you need to be grateful for
you know take care of it shine it do
whatever you got to do sing to it put a
speaker next to your pillow at night
play a little bit of the Beatles you
know something low-key something
meditative for your scalp don't take it
for granted
because hair is a beautiful free
accoutrement from the Lord you know
that's the that's God's top curtain that
you're running around with and you need
to have some gratitude don't just be
yeah let me tell you this you're
ungrateful for your hair it'll find
somewhere else to live and never trust a
farmer this bald-headed are you telling
me you can farm but yeah yeah you can't
take care of that uh that small little
you know millionth of an acre on your
head Kenya you know if you can't grow a
crop up top then I don't know if I'm
gonna stop by your premises and check
out your beets or your squash so but we
got bud Galloway back here in the
distance sometime and um he won't be on
but he is here and he's just gonna check
in every now and then and make sure that
uh everything is record and properly
just get that gander what else can you
be thankful for skin do you have skin
think about skin you have skin on your
body Wow must be nice huh
cuz imagine if you didn't imagine trying
to carry your heart and muscles and
bones around by yourself
it'd be impossible I don't care how good
you can juggle you wouldn't be able to
do anything without your skin so skin
that's something you can be grateful for
and thankful for today show some
gratitude imagine trying to try shoes on
when your bones and everything is all
hanging out and your muscles and your
tendons you know skin very very very
good product very happy imagine going to
the airport and you don't have any
luggage and you got to carry everything
you got to carry your sweaters and your
hats you know and your suspenders and
you got to carry your toothbrush and
toothpaste and everything imagine you
got to carry all of that and you got to
balance you know if you got gifts for
the children you got to balance them on
the the top of your spine or on the top
of your cranium you know or on your head
imagine if you had to do all that it'd
be crazy be impossible to travel like
that wouldn't it well that's what it
would be like if you didn't have skin it
would just be like that just from just
moving around all the time
scaring people you're trying to hug
somebody and they can see your lungs
[ __ ] no nobody's gonna like you so show
some gratitude if you got skin that's
something easy everybody has skin for
the most part unless you were in a fire
and even then you got skin but it's kind
of you know it's a little bit remixed
you know it's a little bit dapped up you
know a little bit daft up by the devil
and that's sometime you get a little bit
more rep till you and you might have a
friend that's you might you know
frequent pet shops or something because
you got a little bit of that lizard
esque in you and that's okay but that's
something to be grateful for that we can
all be grateful for you know and that
skin epidermis that last layer that last
layer that first line of defense against
being ugly and I'm not saying that the
skinless are ugly but I'm not saying
that they aren't let me tell you this
you show up on my front porch skinless
dude
I'll be damned if I don't beat you with
an umbrella like you're a can of tuna
fish out there on Santa Monica Boulevard
because I saw a homeless man beating
open a can of tuna one time when I first
moved here and that would and I'll tell
you this I never thought I would use
that tactic but if a person with no skin
shows up I'll be damned
I'll be damned if they don't take a rain
stopper into one of the eye sockets
because I'll beat somebody's ass with an
umbrella that shows up without any
epidermis so that's something to be
thankful for your skin if you can't
think of anything to be thankful for on
Thanksgiving Day what about your family
think about that what about your
grandmother maybe she has a cat maybe
she doesn't have a cat maybe she just
wears cats my grandmother used to
collect ceramic frogs you know and she
never liked me so those are the two
things I really remember about my
grandmother you know I was thankful you
know that she let me go up to her house
sometimes because they had a big
backyard back there where they grew
strawberries and ah carrots
and she would let me go pick the
strawberries sometime in the morning and
the crows would come down and try to get
at him and so sometime after a while I
got more enticed with uh just scaring
off the crows and let her pick them my
job was that crow handler you know kind
of an early Beastmaster you know kind of
like Edgar Allen Poe's arch-nemesis
fending off crows get out of here you
know my grandma would get pissed cuz
sometimes I throw strawberries at the
crows defeating the purpose of
everybody's activity that day you know
so she's supposed to be picking him and
I'm out there you know throwing him just
that was pretty ignorant of me as a
child but it's Thanksgiving man let me
slow it down a little bit here for you
it is Thanksgiving what are you gonna do
if you're alone you know I just want you
to feel like you're not and sometimes
it's embarrassing to stop in with a
friend or stop at a you know if you
can't go see your family sometimes I can
hurt your feelings a little bit but I
think
just let your family know that you love
them you wish you could be there and
that you'll be there next time
and I'm sure that they'll appreciate
that because they're probably thinking
to you and you go spend some time with
the friend you know you show up with a
with a good attitude Thanksgivings not a
day for bad attitudes you know it's a
day for some really is some gratitude
man you know I had a chance today to
talk to my brother and uh you know and I
love my brother man I used to not I used
to never ever think that I used to have
really very little feelings towards my
brother except maybe some anger just
from not being around when we were young
but today I'm talking to my brother and
he's telling us some problems that he's
having you know some stuff in his life
and it's real stuff you know because
he's he's pretty fortunate in the fact
that he's able to solve some of the
tertiary the smaller items that are
going on in his life but he was talking
about some real stuff and I just
listened to him you know I just listened
and then at the end I just told him I
loved him you know and I told him I told
him so I knew he meant so so he I knew
he knew that I meant it you know it
wasn't just kind of like an outlook all
right man love you you know you know I
knew that he just needed to hear it
and I guess I'm thankful for the fact
that that things can change in a
relationship you know that a leopard
can't change its spots it's one of the
biggest lies in the universe that a
leopard can't change its spots because
years ago I would never have done that I
would have given him some advice for
some guidance not knowing anything like
I do on this show and then I would have
just got off the phone with them you
know but this time I just knew not to
say anything just listen sometimes
people just need somebody to listen so I
guess I'm thankful that today for one of
the first times in my life I felt like I
was able to be a brother you know like I
was just able to I didn't realize I was
being one till afterwards but we got to
untalkative
you know I could tell that he
appreciated me being around and that me
he just appreciated having a brother to
talk to that's all a brother is
sometimes it's just two ears and a heart
that's how you got to be sometimes you
know it's just a sounding board so I'm
thankful for that
she'd be thankful for your family who's
in your family you got anybody somebody
gonna show up to the dinner with a big
mole on their neck mmm we used to have
it one of my dad's friends would show up
this dude was probably one of his
buddies I think he's about 81 years old
and that man had a mole boy he had a
mole that if it saw its shadow boy it
was 90 more years of winter you feel me
and he and that man when he would go
rest when he would rest kind of that
mole would kind of flare out you know
kind of peek its head out it was almost
like when the man would go to sleep the
mole would become awake and as children
we all wanted to get over there and
touch that mole you feel me and so that
was one of our fun games as children was
to get over there and try to touch that
man's mole you know and that's always
something erotic man you know it's it's
one thing to touch somebody on the
breast or in the privates or whatever
but to really get over there and drop a
digit on the top of somebody's mole that
is I mean that's really that's more you
know that's more severe I think think
about that think about your favorite
mole think about it where is it base of
your body up there by your panty line
where is your favorite mole your neck
your cheek somewhere in your hair you
know imagine somebody coming through and
just setting a finger on that mole
that's almost say I don't know if it's
the erotic I don't know what it is but
that's something in it it's really
really something so yeah I'm thinking of
things to be thankful for your family
you don't exist without your parents so
much is a bad-ass you thank you is I'm
gonna tell you this you don't exist
without your parents making love
somewhere and look don't romanticize it
you
we all like to think that our parents
was making love by some you know
beautiful creeks or something out there
in Tennessee
you know we're [ __ ] on the top of a
building or something romantic don't
romanticize it odds are your parents was
watching an episode of in the heat of
the night or Wheel of Fortune you know
and maybe they'd had some kind of you
know a little bit of wine or something
that even you know and your dad was you
know wasn't worried about work and he
came through and caught that boner and
that's how you made it in the universe
let's don't be let's don't let's don't
romanticize the fact that we were all
probably the product of a commercial
break that we were consumed during
advertisement I mean that could be real
man you know now maybe some people were
something romantic happen where they
planned ahead but I don't know when you
think about the times your life when
you've had romantic sex you know I don't
even know but who else your family's
coming you get to see him tell them you
love them you know tell the ones you
hate tell them you love them dude you
ever hug somebody that hates you man
that's the new rodeo right there that's
that new professional bull riding that
PBR
do go hug somebody that hates you and
see if you could stay on for eight
seconds anybody that sends me a video of
that on Thanksgiving or by the end of
this week I will share it hug somebody
that hates you
and see if you can stay on for eight
seconds so see how long you can stay on
send it to me on Twitter or share with
me on Instagram hashtag hug somebody
that hates you I want to see that [ __ ]
dude that would be great man so go do
that let your pets loose pets supposed
to be outside during Thanksgiving dinner
change the game soon as everybody sits
down sneak off say you got to drop some
urine let the Pats in my bath ha ha
I want to wreak havoc dude I was at
somebody's uh Thanksgiving one time is
Jindra and a cat came in and I swear to
God swiped off one of her step
there's a fake eyelashes dude one SWAT
swatting like it's hot man so cats mean
business
they'll change the game you know let
them get in there let them taste
something you know feed a cat something
they're not supposed to eat a little bit
of that jellied cranberry drop that up
in your cat's good and your cat's gullet
see how it feels you know who cares or
something shits on the carpet long as it
ain't you game on it's Thanksgiving
anything goes
choke out your little cousin you got a
cousin don't choke him all the way out
but choke is a little last let him know
what life's gonna be like you know choke
him for four seconds nobody's ever died
in a four-second choke so don't choke
him super hard but yes Thanksgiving what
do you thankful for the air what about
air I was thinking about that earlier
hold your breath hold your breath
and see how long it takes you to be
thankful for air if you're having
trouble finding gratitude hold your
breath see where else your lungs go
looking for replenishment there's
nowhere so you'll learn gratitude in a
heartbeat
learn about 30 heartbeats usually
because you'll need air fast and that's
one way to just immediately condition
yourself to feel some gratitude oh and
when you feel that feeling of your lungs
feel after your inhale that's gratitude
that's what gratitude is feeling
grateful feeling grateful so sometimes
that's a you know that's just a
foolproof method to kick start your own
gratitude but I want to say that I'm
thankful for you guys you know I'm gonna
sing a song right here all right though
some of the people that has helped out
on patreon so I'm not want anybody to
feel less Sam because they haven't
helped on patreon but I want those
people to know you know that I'm
grateful for them you know because I
really really am
what a McCool crazy Roberts tie Olli
[ __ ]
Charlie dad I'm where your morrow scoffs
word Lauren crib John Ross
Jacob our tango need are receiving or
mine Cielo person hey LeBron given be it
Swiss column on there's some more people
that have helped out on the patreon so
I'm dropping that and I got a few more
here I'm a rattle them off real quick
throats throw this stuff up alright let
me get you that deal include chat so
let's me Robert do see it Christian from
Bakersfield Brian Kevin Doyle Kevin
Doyle Susanne O'Reilly Greg H Brian G up
on him on famous Jess who with on Andre
Alana and Aaron yawns those are the gun
squatters on the patreon and I
appreciate everybody who helps out on
patreon because I just want to show that
I'm thankful and there'll be some
extended footage from today's
Thanksgiving episode that is gonna go on
a patreon that's not going to be a very
long episode but I just want to say that
I'm so grateful for all you guys the
littlest things that helped out to make
this thing possible you know now I don't
know what this thing is but we're
growing and people's getting on board
you know and we're trying to be about
some [ __ ] you know my boy sure about
there a man you know hit me up in the
from the darkness and offered in the
middle of the night to I mean I'm
talking to 3:00 4:00 a.m. I'm talking
and this man getting up and doing the
audio week after week after week a year
now we've been on the air well not
really saw a lot fifty but we have 52
episodes including some Thursday
episodes so I'm thankful I'm thankful to
the 30,000 listeners that we had last
week man
what is it I'm thankful to tiny sand to
a man who if you could see the emails
that he sends in you would I mean is it
a man is it a child is it an 8 year old
with a beautiful piece of uh musical
equipments and he's doing things you
know is he locked in a basement is he
trapped in a genie lamp where is tiny
sand - where's he living is he in prison
where is he do we need to sign up for
Amnesty International in high school
do remember Amnesty International it was
like this group it was a bunch of people
eating apples and [ __ ] and writing
letters to prisoners and stuff and
smoking dope and usually whatever
teacher help run that class in high
school was also smoking dope or selling
dope but I'm thankful man I'm thankful
to you guys you know I'm thankful to my
boy Ken Highland a tall man who have a
six year old son named Wyatt who has a
space in his teeth and is a beautiful
boy and he and its episodes every week
for pay but still he helps hide he works
overtime help me put this studio
together I want to thank Ari Maness he's
come in here and been victimized by our
listeners you know but he's come in here
and helped get this podcast to some new
levels gray block pizza all of our
sponsors anybody who's ever helped out
in you guys you which ears driving
around care what you're doing if you got
there selling crack cocaine at least
you're listening to the podcast in the
morning and I'm grateful well what else
can you be thankful for do you have legs
you have no legs you got arms
do you have arms or you just like that
one guy on the internet who has no legs
and no arms and gives all some speeches
at churches not Church's Chicken
religious establishments you know what
I'm talking about there's a lot of
forwards out there on Facebook of that
man I've seen that man I've seen in
person in person live down at the Garden
Grove Church down there at Crystal
Cathedral the hour of power the one used
to see on the Internet
before they got busted for swindling
people out of their cash what else you
could you be grateful for what about a
bath huh you ever felt out in the shower
you couldn't get up and the water filled
up around you surprise [ __ ]
you're not injured that's a bath that's
a free bath be grateful you know you
ever missed work cuz you were in a fire
yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up right you
lost half your [ __ ] but you also didn't
have to go in be grateful for ants the
little things
what about ants not your uncle's wife
I'm talking about creatures I talked
with the little ones
midgets of the life-force ants ever been
to a picnic and not cleaned up after
yourself yeah well somebody did be
grateful for that there's a million
things to be grateful for I only got two
I had a lot of callers that came in some
about relationships I actually have I
got a confession I got to make to you
guys I'm gonna do it on this upcoming
episode though on the next Monday's
episode you know I got a you know I just
I got to deal with that some stuff I got
to deal with someone talked to you about
it on Monday but here's some callers
that came in just two of them and I want
to uh and I want to UM I want you to
hear this here we go hey what's the feel
this is a vein now here in Ontario I've
called before
what's up Zayn in Ontario onward I was
just calling man for a couple things do
the first one I just want to say I hope
you have a happy Thanksgiving I
appreciate that Zayn we had a couple
colors that were called in and mentioned
Thanksgiving in their in their call but
I want to but I want to thank Zayn a
hundred percent Thank You sane Albert
I'm gonna be spending it with my
daughter and a few loved ones and I hope
you you uh you're spending it with some
loved ones two men that and then also I
don't know if you're still taking ideas
about a tiny sand whoo but in my mind I
pictured tiny sand who being like like
this baby like horse was like giant
hands like a floor and instead of like
that Thor hammer he has that that bass
guitar man I don't know dude that's kind
of want pictured in my head but who
knows man could be couldn't be I love it
I love your attitude you're right it
could be couldn't be but that's what he
pictures on eat ants tiny sand to a baby
horse out there you know with special
hands special you know special hands
musical hands and that's another thing
some people you get out you know
everybody wants to get a you don't have
a leg you got to get a you know my boy
Pat from Alabama got a fake leg get a
[ __ ] guitar put into your body you
idiot you know you got a fake leg get a
flute down there this is Pat he's got
three appendages and a [ __ ]
flute it's just we keep limiting
ourselves with bad ideas but I like your
idea brothers tiny saying who could be
anything he could be anything we want
and as far as I know he's a being from
the great beyond that has reached out to
us with some mad little riffs
and we're grateful for him and thank you
man you're gonna spend it with your new
daughter I wanna hear that one more time
I'm gonna spend it with your daughter
let me hear this and for a couple things
do the first one I just wanted to say I
hope you have a happy Thanksgiving I'm
gonna be spending it with my daughter
and a few loved ones and I help you
that's awesome man that's awesome enjoy
that time show up for your your daughter
you know don't watch the whole football
game you watch half of it on mute and
spend time with them for the other half
you know and I just say this cuz I was a
child and I wish that my parents would
have done some of those things with me
you know I have a lot of strong memories
of the holidays because I don't think
there was real super times when I was
young but you know just make an effort
if you're out there make an effort I
don't have any loved ones that I'll be
spending time with but I will be
spending time with some friends and
family and I'm very grateful and I'm
gonna try to show up I'm gonna try to be
awake all day and and just be present
you know and I'm gonna try to smile and
laugh and I'm gonna try to [ __ ] hug a
[ __ ] that hates me
you know but thank you and I appreciate
hope you have a happy Thanksgiving let's
hear one more caller and this is in
response to the dark arts um we needed
more black or african-american callers
we got one let's go yeah oh you
beautiful Burley beignet awesome dude
Happy Thanksgiving
hello onward you ever have powdered
sugar sprinkled on your head breath
anyways what's up Theo that's Ryan from
sac town Ryan from sac town man that was
a good impersonation man I like it
thankful I'm thankful you're making me
smile right now man let's hear more
thank you for calling Sacramento the
land of where everybody looks like a
missing person true
oh we're I thought I'd just call in and
give my perspective on do black guys get
nervous oh good and this was a topic on
last week's episode and thank you for
calling in about it do black guys get
nervous my original theory was no they
do not
my newer hypothesis is that it's a
case-by-case basis but I still believe
that black people do better at handling
their nerves I think it may be due to
the struggles they've been through that
nerves are too small of an issue to keep
- to debilitate a black man onward my
mom's black my dad's black so make me
black so I think I'm qualified to maybe
give my opinion on the situation we got
a hundred percent guys let's hear it
let's hear it I feel like I get nervous
sometimes I'm hanging out with white
guys dude I've done that that has
happened to me a lot that's most of my
life actually but let's hear more like
some of my wife friends like to do some
extreme things sometimes I had a friend
who you know he came down with a sudden
case of the Vandy you know he was into
some light vandalism oh that Vandy boy
of course I know about that we were out
for his birthday and this guy wants to
playfully open up car doors or kick some
shrubbery and people's lawns I said man
you know we can't be doing that and he
said man what are you being all crazy
for he's like it's fun just give it a
try and I said no we can't do that you
know he didn't understand why wasn't
okay you know he was one black dude and
a bunch of us are one white dude with a
bunch of black dudes and we're out and
he was like y'all you guys are with me
it's fine like we could do this so that
was a situation where I feel like I was
kind of nervous you know you don't know
what's gonna happen thank you for
calling man that's a nut look that's a
great scenario it's like yeah if you if
it the one white dude yeah he could do
whatever you know he could juggle his
own dick in the air if he wants to if he
has more than one day you know he can do
whatever he wants you know he could
drink his blood out in the middle of the
street and people are like oh he's a
vampire you know he could open car doors
and people are like oh it's a fun game
but if a black guy does some of those
things yeah immediately a lot quicker
you guys might be susceptible to
having a gun drawn on you or - you know
- yeah to be an accused or being shy
mean anything there's a lot more the
potential see I could understand that
that if you're out with a whitey to it
and he starts acting wild if he starts
whiting off then you could get nervous
man you could get real real nervous
because you like to him
this is the dude that's gonna get us in
trouble you know but yeah man I mean you
could go back into the reasoning behind
like why cops think that and why cops
are more nervous around black people
instead of other people you know and
there's a lot of different you know
there's a lot in all that we're not
getting in all that but I appreciate
that call I appreciate you listening
over there in sac Sacramento and I
appreciate I'm glad that we have a voice
we can go to you know that we're not
just a you know that we're not just that
this is an an environment where a lot of
people are listening and we're trying to
keep things diverse because we want to
have a conversation here about all kinds
of stuff you know we're moving forward
and I appreciate your call happy
Thanksgiving to you and to your family
happy Thanksgiving everybody you know
I'm gonna call it animal reel it in I
hope you have a beautiful day I hope you
love somebody I hope you love yourself
you know I hope you catch that hit off
that Turkey I hope you don't drink any
cured coffee you know how I feel about
that and I just want to say that I'm
thankful for all you guys take care of
yourselves Thank You Spencer Jacob thank
you gun squad
Thank You bud Galloway think you're sure
I think you can Highland Thank You
Thomas I think you bill Morris thank you
to my friends thank you all you guys
love you and I'll see you on Mondays
episode happy Thanksgiving to you and
yours a celebrate living at least do it
today
[Music]
celebrate
all right but you hear the blame is
[Music]
you'll die